get ready to take your taste buds on a
trip around the world while supporting
our las vegas community at the
gramercy's taste of the gramercy this
saturday now joining us is bryce
crossman the owner of dw bistro and joe
mcaulish with anima by edo welcome you
guys thank you for having us who came up
with this brilliant concept
well i mean listen we've been in the
gramercy for six years now and we're so
happy to have anima as a neighbor now uh
we've been following their food for a
long time with idotapus and uh we're
just thrilled to offer you know a little
fair from every place including pinches
tacos as well as us so how's it going to
work this weekend you buy your tickets
in advance you go out there you try
different food walk me through the
process so you're going to go to
secretburger.com jolene and her team
over there is really good about throwing
lots of really great vegas events and
you'll get a little ticket that will
take you to our restaurant and to joe's
restaurant and to pinches tacos for a
little taste of each spot so this is
like my passport on saturday exactly
okay what are we making we'll start with
the cocktails and we'll start with the
food
let's drink first so the featured
cocktail with us gin tonics is probably
one of the most famous cocktails of our
restaurant group um so being anima being
a little bit more of a italian
restaurant melfi gin comes from southern
part of italy so we always
recommend starting with stuff like that
that's going to be the featured cocktail
for the tasting of the gramercy so uh
it's really simple melfi gin tends to be
a very very elegant style of gin very
citrus based um
definitely like the most favorite we add
it with cucumber tonic water it's very
refreshing why go cucumber just for that
refreshing twist to it refreshing moving
in the summer people associate that with
a lot of a little bit more clenching of
the palette a little more acidic with
the citrus as well we add juniper into
it as well this definitely one of the
more common aromas in gin
right it's a gorgeous cocktail
you can smell all this i mean as soon as
you do that little yup exactly the
flavor we can smell it here we got the
ice cubes too i love the big chunk ice
cubes right that's my style right it's
the best it doesn't dilute the drink but
it keeps it chilled mm-hmm and it's a
perfect glass and then too someone told
me have that kind of ice cube you should
keep remaking using that ice cube so you
can't absorbing the flavor every other
drink you add on to it multiple drinks
yeah yeah yeah you get more and more
flavors
exactly that looks delicious thank you
thank you and that definitely gets you
ready for the spice of jamaica okay so
chef dalton our founding chef here at dw
bistro coming from jamaica we have our
jerk seasoning don't get too close to
that because we'll have a little sneeze
fest and then you have uh carrots and
you have our pickled red onions and our
jerk pork so we're putting it on a
cheddar biscuit
and why don't cheddar biscuits oh
because it's a good flavor with
everything else it calms the heat of the
jerk pork down you know i'm just using
my hands
they're clean and they're fine we're
friends here we are and then we're going
to put our carrots on top just a couple
carrots so do we talk about costs what
about the cost for this weekend 79 so
you get two tastes as well as a cocktail
at each place
and there's live music in the courtyard
we have a really beautiful courtyard
that we love to use there in the space
at gramercy and uh so it'll just be a
really fun night on saturday the weather
is supposed to be great and everything
you guys do there's always a charity
tie-in which i love joey's giving back
to las vegas who are you working with
this we're working with shade tree this
weekend for our drinks as well so um
you'll definitely want to come check us
out why shade tree this year you know
what they just are a great organization
they've been around a long time and i
think it's just it's an opportunity for
us to work with them and to uh to give
back
you mentioned to your courtyard i mean
that's the place to have parties it's
stunning outside there the weather this
weekend is going to be spectacular none
of that wind no it's not gone
it's gonna be the perfect weekend
with delicious cocktails amazing food
and all for a great cause as well
absolutely gentlemen thank you so much
thank you wait pass that down oh yes yes
i mean please do it please we have to
toast this right oh yeah jillian's over
there she's all jealous so cheers here's
her great weekend success to you guys
appreciate it julian over to you my
friend i'm sad over here you're having a